[Music]
holy crap everybody can you believe that
they actually did the black costume we
were talking about it all over last year
there was that Instagram tease where he
posted a picture very clearly black
fabric but then they had all the edits
and people were talking about different
versions of the script so not only do
you see the black costume you also see
his warframe from the comics I believe
that that's a version of this like when
he comes back in the black costume after
the return of Superman art he comes back
to fight cyborg superman and drops out
of the warframe like over my dead body
you're going to destroy this city
because you can clearly see that his lip
is not CG I think that this was actually
from the Zack Snyder cut of the film
there's been so much talk about that - I
don't want to get too much into that but
if you're one of the conspiracy
theorists then there has been more
evidence recently especially just round
about things that Zack Snyder has done
on social media to indicate that there
is actually a Zack Snyder cut that they
could do if they wanted but what it
seems like is happening right now
there's going to be one version of the
blu-ray and this is one of the deleted
scenes from that so they have like a
mishmash of deleted scenes so pretty
standard blu-ray release it's not gonna
be a version of Batman V Superman or
Suicide Squad where there's like an
extended cut of the film but you look at
him here walking onto the Scout ship and
obviously they're playing his Man of
Steel theme song it is you see him walk
up and frame he's not wearing shoes and
he's wearing the plaid shirt that you
saw him in after he came back to the
Kent farm so he wakes up they have that
conversation about how he needs to go
help the Justice League out and he needs
to do what's right
has the reunion with Martha Kent then
goes back to the scoutship and this
scene picks up and this takes place
before he puts on that tuned-up version
of the blue costume and goes back into
battle to help the Justice League with
Steppenwolf
[Music]
so there was any confusion about where
this was supposed to appear it was after
this but before this and I think the
whole idea with this black costume
reveal is it was a big wink at the
comics like hey look we're doing the
comic book thing and here's the warframe
from the comics wouldn't it be so badass
if he wore that but very clearly what it
seems like the scene is implying is that
he walks in and they just automatically
open up offering him access to whatever
he might need he turns and looks at
another pod that we don't see that opens
up and you to see him considering it for
a moment that's probably the blue
version of the costume that he then puts
on and flies into battle so yes it seems
like there was black costume but I don't
think that they had the idea to make him
wear it or if he was going to wear it it
was an early version of the script
because there's all these apocryphal
stories about how they rewrote the movie
to change how Superman came back like in
the version that we saw in theaters they
bring him back using the mother box but
that's not the original way that he was
supposed to come back there was supposed
to be this whole Darkseid arc where he
resurrects Superman and mind controls
him to fight the Justice League
so like when he's fighting them at his
Monument there that's a Zack Snyder
scene but the context for during the
original version of the movie was
completely different from what we saw
the easiest way to tell what they
changed from the original version of the
movie is just looking for when that CG
mustache removal shows up so like do you
bleed
that's a reshoot a lot of the scenes
that were cut into that final fight are
reshoots as well like there's actually
scenes that you can tell where its
original Henry Cavill so Zack Snyder had
a version of him fighting in this area
here but it was completely different
they changed the whole ending of the
film so they had to reshoot a bunch of
these fight scenes
which is why he goes from looking normal
like when he dodges the fists here this
is original Zack Snyder footage then you
go to the next scene right after that
here and it's CG mustache removal so
it's clearly a reshoot so really cool
that they actually did the return of
Superman from the comics of your big
comic book band and if not then you
probably didn't miss it but now you know
why people were freaking out about
potential black costume last year but
let me know in the comments what do you
guys think about this and do you
actually think there was a version of
the movie where he
where's that costume because if Zack
Snyder shot this scene then very clearly
he did not intend for him to wear the
black costume when he flew into battle
for the final time but what might have
happened in like the original three and
a half or four hour cut of the film
Steppenwolf might have resurrected
Superman then he goes and puts the black
costume on bites them then Batman brings
in Lois as was originally intended as
implied by Batman V Superman Lois is the
key and then he goes off gets his head
on straight comes back to the Scout ship
puts the blue costume back on then goes
and joins the Justice League as a fan of
Justice you may have seen some of the
concept art too because obviously they
cut this film way down I think it was
like an hour and 59 minutes it was like
right around two hours long so I think
the original plan was for the film to be
around two and a half hours just because
they had this whole Darkseid story that
they cut out of the film and you've
probably seen some of the deleted scenes
with the other characters that gives
cyborg some more backstory give flash
some more backstory there was like a
whole iris West scene that they cut out
of the film because they knew that they
were gonna be making some changes with
the flashpoint movie and they wanted
whoever the new director that was going
to come in to be able to recast the iris
West role if they wanted to which is a
whole other story but it's coming out on
blu-ray really soon so you guys will be
able to see all the deleted scenes or at
least some of them I don't think they're
gonna include everything but there was
actually a legit amount of finished CG
that they had done for a bunch of the
original Zack Snyder cut before they
shifted gears into a more positive
direction like they wanted to make a
more hopeful film I think the Zack
Snyder cut was just more of like the
uber dark violent stuff that he had done
in previous films but maybe we'll never
know who knows I'm sure a Comic Con in
like 10 years
if Zack Snyder goes back ever people can
ask him those questions maybe he'll
answer them because I don't think that
he's gonna be making any superhero films
with Warner Brothers anytime soon but if
you guys didn't know in related DC movie
universe news they're shooting the
Shazam movie right now Zachary Levi
posted a picture of him covered up but
wearing the Shazam costume he's like I'm
wearing it underneath this coat
obviously he couldn't show it to us now
we know that the people that did
spider-man homecoming are doing the
Justice League flashpoint movie but
we'll probably find out more about that
at Comic Con because now that they've
locked down their directors they're
gonna rewrite the script they'll
probably have some more news about like
hey this is the spin we're gonna do
these are the characters we're thinking
about in clue
but as far as Matt Reeves Batman Ben
Affleck there haven't been any updates
about that people are saying that he's
just waiting to read the script like
maybe he'll still do it but now it's
looking like he might not do it henry
cavill on the other hand is totally down
to do more Superman movies like he's
been doing interviews I posted those
videos a while ago where he's like you
know how do you want them to explain
Clark Kent being dead and then coming
back I think right now the plan is until
they find a really solid idea for the
next Man of Steel movie and lock down a
director they'll just look for places
that they can add him in movies for
cameos where relevant so like I did a
Shazam video explaining why that's a
really good place for him to pop up
Wonder Woman is also really solid pick
just because those characters are kind
of in the same tone in the DC movies but
speaking of which we actually learned
that the working title of the Wonder
Woman movie is Magic Hour seeming to
imply that Cersei will be the big bill
into that just because magic as in
literal magic but winking from behind
the camera because Magic Hour is
actually a filmmaking term that people
use to describe this really small window
of time where the Sun hasn't quite set
yet and you get this really awesome
orange glow but because this was such a
surprise I'll go ahead and do a new
round of that blast ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and share the video using
those tools on the watch page I'll name
a winner when I post new DC this weekend
I wasn't expecting this to drop so there
are some other Marvel videos that I want
to post so I'll try to get that out as
fast as possible but click here for my
new flash promo and click here for that
new Avengers infinity war promo thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight